[Musique]
dans la vie il ya 70 ans sur l'île ne
devait pas être la même qu'aujourd'hui
il y avait beaucoup de prières beaucoup
de sens par et pour commencer je vais
vous dire je ne sais pas très bien de
france est un
c'est pourquoi oui pas sûr toutefois on
parlait toujours le breton si nous ne
pas décoller enfin on signalait
découlent mais moi je ne ressentais pas
beaucoup parce que j'avais des petits
frères à la maison il fallait que je
reste occupée de mes petits frères pour
aider ma mère alors c'est pour ça que je
suis resté un peu arriérés que vous ne
disent pas mais non dans les travers de
l'enfant j'ai beaucoup de fautes
j'ai une vie loin du monde loin de 1
vivien on vient vigan très bien mais on
s'en faisait
on s'amusait aussi lui n'avait pas de
cinéma n'aurait pas la télé ni et
beaucoup l'ont dit rien comme en alcool
comme on a maintenant je vais super de
ce nom levitt retard nous c'est avec la
lampe à pétrole
la bougie oui tous les soirs alors on
était en famille le soir à tricoter
affaire dé la veillée pour l'hiver
c'était bien l'inversé là on arrivait à
vivre heureux à huîtres et craignent que
les femmes les femmes travaillent au
sens et les sculptures est beaucoup plus
que maintenant au secours cultiver tous
tout lille tout les champs de lire
maintenant ils sont restés en vie parce
que les jeunes sont partir continent
travailler il n'ya pas d'animaux donc
les horaires ci y avait des vaches
oui y'en a plus y'en a pas n'a pas en
fait c'est une grande fille tu quand on
retenait le corps sont liés
ça c'était pour passer l'hiver parce que
le courrier ne pouvait pas faire tout
pour toujours sa traversée et l'été
empêché plus qu'on ait lieu
on laisse aller on les fait sécher et
pendant l'hiver on trouvait ça on puis
c'est ça qu'on fait l'amour humain
oui c'était bon ça nous jouerons on aime
ça
aujourd'hui je veux moi je fais du
projet maintenant je passe mon temps à
faire du fond c'est s'occuper des trois
de mes petits-enfants pour voir où ils
sont comme ça
belga vous portez madame également une
robe noire et toutes les femmes de l'île
de sein porte une golf noire
contrairement à celle du continent qui
ont un golf blanche et une raison à cela
oh c'est depuis toujours pour les femmes
de ville port de la pointe noire on est
tous un noah redessine alliés
autrefois il y avait beaucoup de 9h à
venir il c'est comme ça beaucoup de
marques beaucoup de mal dans ma jeune
vie se marier sur l'île avec des gens
lille où elle se laisse d'ailleurs avec
des jeunes gens de l'île sera c'est rare
qu'on se marier et ailleurs toi famille
ses amis
c'est ce qui fait qu'on retrouve
beaucoup de familles qui porte le même
nom oui y'en a beaucoup de cousins
cousines miss est presque toujours des
parlementaires fouquet est cher et tout
ça et vous avez toujours vécu dans ce
film
oui j'avais que toujours et il ne vous
est jamais venu à l'idée
à 20 ans par exemple d'en partir dans
les livres sur leur bilan ou ailleurs or
on jamais
scharner ni les gens j'ai pas rue
d'etion signer une idée jeunechamp de
l'île partir de lille non plus
c'était à la presse de la pêche mais
elle est ainsi travailler la terre
pour ça mais non c'est pas la même chose
il faut vivre a dit maintenant comment
vous allez voyager quand même vous fait
il visait voyager ce voyage et je me dis
bruit assez bien quand je pars de lille
mais autrefois je trouvais mieux la vie
d'autrefois que maintenant parce que
comment je vous dirais ont des titres
sans famille j'aimais mieux autrefois
qu'aujourd'hui je vous dirais un propos
m'ont aidé à voir
[Musique]